so how long have you been ant-man again
now uh and just sort of happened
chuckles like bad guys like you
I seem to mess it up almost every time
[Applause]
maybe you just need someone watch your
back
like a partner
[Music]
back pain I actually heard what happened
to you you open up the quantum realm
that's when his crazy could be ghosts
and like walks through walls and stuff
slowly otech now supposed to take over
the world or whatever
who would have believed that in your
hour of need you would turn the house at
me bleep robbed you do you remember
that's us feeling chance regret this
oath the deal
and man in the wasp teaming up follow my
lead
[Music]
she seems more intense
you go low I'll go high I have wings why
would I go low
[Music]
hey what'd I miss we were just tiny
I was partners with Hank on a project
called Goliath how big did you get my
record 21 feet
you've 65 feet 65 if you to our flesh
comparing sizes 65 hey everybody is
Charlie this is gonna be my ant-man at
the Worcester trailer video I'll also
explain how this is tied to infinity war
and Avengers 4 because the movies coming
out after infinity war but it starts
before the events of infinity war if you
are finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're just getting started with ant-man
and the wasp and Avengers 4 stuff -
there's gonna be a bunch of Marvel
dropping this week the big MacGuffin
this time not so much being the Pym
particles but being the actual quantum
realm itself like they say that the
ghosts stole his tech when he opened up
the quantum realm but we also get a good
look at the ghost with her mask off so
it's a gender bent ghost it's Hannah Jon
came in in the comics ghost is just a
super thief not a grand world conquering
villain in the vein of Magneto or
someone like Loki in the first Avengers
movie so the quantum realm is the
MacGuffin of the film we'll see what it
is that they pull from that that the
super villain wants so much that will
allow them to take over the world
because there's usually people abusing
or stealing Pym technology then trying
to use that to take over the world like
Hydra was trying to get it during the
first ant-man movie this movie although
you know mostly this movie has been
pitched to me as the rescue of the
original wasp Janet Van Dyne played by
Michelle Pfeiffer from the quantum realm
so while this ghost quantum realm high
stuff is probably what gives them the
reason to go back into the quantum realm
and then think about rescuing Janet Van
Dyne so there's still a lot of
information that we don't have about the
quantum realm in this trailer yet but it
does look like this shot is the og wasp
because hopes costume has yellow
highlights the og wasp costume has red
highlights you may have noticed that
she's on the poster though in her
original wasp costume you don't get a
really good look at her because she's
behind Scott here but this is what she's
going to look like in present day when
they come out of the quanta
realm so the idea being that this is a
prequel to infinity war they want it to
be like a fun heist film that's a bit of
a respite from the dire consequences of
infinity war like everyone's kind of
reeling from the end of that movie they
want to have a fun summer movie these
heroes are gonna be bigger characters
during Avengers 4 there needs to be some
connective tissue so the big theory now
is that they go into the quantum realm
at some point in the movie time moves
differently there they're probably
protected from Thanos as finger-snap
it would be an amazing post-credit scene
if they came back out of the quantum
realm to a post finger-snap universe and
they just looked around hey where did
everybody go Scott Lang could lose his
daughter usually it's everybody losing
who they love most but Sebastian Stan
did say that there was a shot during
Avengers 4 where they had like everybody
on screen together he did reveal that
Hank Pym and Michelle Pfeiffer's Janet
Van Dyne were amongst people in that
crowd of the shot that they did meaning
that they might not get turned to ash
during the course of a man in the wasp
maybe because they're also in the
quantum realm with hope and Scott either
way we get to Avengers 4 Hank Pym in
Michelle Pfeiffer's Janet Van Dyne are
alive at some point though remember we
all expect those people that got turned
to ash to come back and I think that
they're all in the soul world but we'll
see how the movie explains that just
remember that the gems are still intact
regardless of Venice's melted looking
gauntlet but if the whole idea of its
soul world is a different dimension
within the soul gem in the quantum realm
is a different dimension that they
shrink down into maybe they'll find a
creative way to use ant-man and the wasp
abilities besides just getting really
big like there's a lot of comedy that
they use here like oh my god we were all
small for a second like I'm shrinking
the car down underneath the other car
then growing it back up so the car flies
out of the way there's a lot of like
haha funny them jumping into cars taking
villains down that's like a very
low-level use of their abilities think
about quantum realm as being more of the
grand fulfillment of those abilities you
can take it way beyond this funny boss
battle here so then you know how do they
use that during Avengers 4 let me know
in the comments though how do they use
their abilities during Avengers 4
besides just becoming giant man like
they have the Lawrence
bernd Goliath joke he's a big comic book
character too I'll talk about him in a
second oh how big did you get 21 feet
you know like it's a pretty badass thing
you know I went sixty five feet and then
they actually show you him going sixty
five feet in the bay there the whole
thing with that is that there is an
actual physical limit that human bone
can go to like eventually human bone
will just get so brittle it's not meant
to support a certain amount of weight
that's why there's a limit on how big
Scott can get like he can't just keep
getting bigger and bigger and bigger
eventually his body would break in half
because his bones couldn't support the
weight because as he gets bigger his
bones do not get stronger they just get
bigger but the whole thing with Goliath
is is that when hank pym became giant
man there was a period in the comics
where he got stuck at a minimum of ten
feet like he couldn't get bigger than
ten feet tall the avengers needed
somebody who could get bigger so hank
pym suggested bill foster goliath became
the new giant man for a period during
the comics but this is like way back
during the 70s so the funny thing about
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is like
they say that Ant Man was young and
active during the Cold War like that's
when Janet Van Dyne was lost to the
quantum realm was back during the 80s
you have to imagine that around that
same time they were also doing these
Goliath experiments so just imagine a
young version of Laurence Fishburne
being a protege of a younger version of
Michael Douglas sort of like a Tony
Stark Spider Man situation but we'll see
you know like usually Hank Pym has a lot
of fallout in the relationships of his
life so let's see what their
relationship is like in present day
Laurence Fishburne like in this office
seems like he's doing relatively normal
stuff but they all reminisce about the
awesome stuff that they used to do like
oh yeah we used to do really cool stuff
but now we're just like normal
scientists for those of you worried the
TI wasn't gonna be in the film I got a
lot of comments about this is TI going
to be an ant-man and the wasp confirmed
Ti in ant-man and the wasp so no worries
there but it does look like they've
hilariously tried to upgrade their
security business although mostly it's
them breaking in places but maybe it's
like a sneaker situation where they're
breaking into businesses to prove where
the security flaws are so maybe they're
still doing the exact same thing except
trying to pass it off like it's a legit
business but there's something about him
wearing that suit that just makes this
funnier like him just trying to pretend
to be a totally legit businessman just
to bring it back around to infinity war
during the course of the movie they said
that ant-man and Hawkeye were on house
arrest because Captain America broke
them out of the raft remember they had
already been arrested after the airport
battle they said that they cut a deal
because their families just couldn't
deal with them being on the run so
during the events of infinity war
Hawkeye is back with his family on the
farm in Scott is with his family where
they believed that ant-man has been with
his family but like at the beginning of
the trailer his daughters like how long
have you been ant-man again because we
don't see any of that house arrest
bracelet we saw in the first trailer so
that's probably the very beginning of
the timeline right after Civil War so it
just makes sense that at the end of the
movie there's a post-credits scene that
deals with the post finger-snap universe
where half of all people are gone or
maybe they come back out of the quantum
realm and Scott goes to kiss his
daughter goodnight and she just starts
to turn to ash but what I'll do next is
is I'll do an infinity war video for all
the missing characters like Valkyrie
Korg meek Adam warlock the Celestials
the Watchers so that should post in a
couple hours congratulations to the
latest Infinity Gauntlet giveaway winner
Leandro Escobar please private message
me so I can get your contact details
click here for all my infinity war
Easter eggs and click here for my top 10
WTF after the movie thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]